I'm gonna do this I regret to say that
the first love letter I ever wrote was
written after I had received my first
love letter and then that's what
inspired me to write love letters me and
my first love which is fitting would
write each other letters she wrote me a
lot more letters than I ever wrote her
but we're just little things like I love
you today or I hope you're having a
great day miss you or just remember your
mind heart and smiley face or whatever
cute little things like that
this reminders a love candles well what
is it smell it this candle it's like a
light blue which means it's probably
sweet and I don't like sweet candle wait
I want like a like glass like a dark rum
Oh woodsy I've met someone on Instagram
and like I develop this like ostensibly
intimate relationship with them and then
turns out they weren't who they were as
catfishing does oh I think I think maybe
once or twice they were in the script
but I say well we'll all the time whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa okay relax
first job was working as a model at
eight years old out of Miami and I it
was for a Macy's catalog I was a little
Macy's baby and then their time 14 years
ago and then I like dry it and just
shake it whenever we were doing like
stuff like this so I can talk to you
guys there's like this spray just like
sea salt spray so it is sea salt spray
that like makes it look like I just got
out the ocean
stop there first thing you do when you
wake up I go right back to sleep it's
the first thing I do I cannot wake up
and be like alright today's gonna be
fantastic I wake up and I go no not yet
Shantaram by Gregory David Roberts the
whole book is very poetic and it's a
it's a journey from deep diving into the
abyss and then coming back from it and
transcending and changing and Manning
and it's a beautiful read do you think
you
I charge introverted Lea and then I
really it has a great
[Music]
you
[Music]